[Musique]
en 2022 l'Union européenne annonce au
sommet de l'aviation de Toulouse vouloir
la neutralité carbone d'ici 2050 le défi
est immense on parle dans le secteur
aérien de 1550 milliards de dollars
d'investissement pour les 30 prochaines
années
pour y parvenir Airbus explore plusieurs
pistes en 2022 l'entreprise réalise une
prouesse technique faire voler un Airbus
A380 avec un moteur alimenté par 100% de
carburant durable constitué
principalement d'huile de cuisson usagés
mais vous allez voir Airbus s'est lancé
un défi encore plus fou cet avion va
être celui qui va être utilisé comme
laboratoire volant pour tester les
technologies hydrogène qui sont
développées par Airbus l'hydrogène est
quand même un carburant très prometteur
parce que c'est l'un des seuls ou le
seul qui permet d'avoir zéro émission de
CO2 à la sortie à la sortie du moteur de
l'avion cet avion qui va servir de
cobaye pour les tests ne va pas
totalement être modifié il va conserver
ses 4 réacteurs traditionnels donc le
cinquième moteur sera installé au-dessus
de l'avion donc sur une sur une
excroissance qui ressemblera une petite
voilure à une petite aile qui sera en
gros entre la dérive et la porte que
vous voyez là bas et donc sur un texte
croissance qu'on appelle un stop on sera
capable d'installer plusieurs types de
moteur à hydrogène l'objectif est de
comparer le comportement des réacteurs
traditionnels avec celui à l'hydrogène
ce qui inquiète les ingénieurs ce ne
sont pas les moteurs mais les réservoirs
d'hydrogène à l'intérieur du fuselage
donc là on est à l'arrière de l'avion
vraiment près de la de la queue de
l'avion on se trouve sur le pont
principal et dans cette zone là on va
stocker l'hydrogène qui va être utilisé
pour les essais donc l'hydrogène va être
stockée sous forme liquide c'est à dire
à moins de 153 degrés donc c'est ce
qu'on appelle de l'hydrogène cryogénique
il faut savoir que sous cette forme là
l'hydrogène va contenir trois fois plus
d'énergie que ce qu'on pourrait avoir
dans un dans du carburant classique dans
du kérosène mais va être en contrepartie
quatre fois plus volumineux donc le défi
du stockage de l'hydrogène et quelque
chose de clé et sur lequel on va
travailler sur ce projet là air c'est
fixé pour objectif de réaliser les
premiers vols fin 2026 si les tests sont
concluants un premier avion hydrogène
pourrait voir le jour en 2035
mais l'énergie et l'amélioration des
moteurs ne sont pas les seules pistes
explorées par Airbus pour voyager plus
écolo
chez opnext la filiale d'Airbus chargée
d'accélérer le développement des
technologies futures on s'intéresse aux
ailes qui équiperont les avions de
demain
est liée à la performance de l'avion et
la performance de l'avion est donnée par
les designs des tonnelles et qui soit
capable de réduire les émissions et la
consommation des carburants des 5 à 10%.
voici la maquette de l'aile du futur en
taille réelle elle mesure à 5 mètres de
plus que celle qui équipe actuellement
nos avions et ressemblera aux ailes des
albatros
qui vont modifier la forme à redynamique
de la délai pendant toutes les phases du
vol une aile ultra performante qui
s'adaptera aux conditions météo et qui
fera mieux face au vent pour optimiser
sa consommation de carburant des
solutions il en existe pour les avions
de ligne et gros porteurs mais qu'en
est-il pour l'aviation légère considérez
comme polluantes bruyante ou réservé à
une élite l'aviation de loisirs en
France c'est 51 milliards d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires en 2020 dont 33
milliards à l'export au niveau de la
finition on va pas avoir besoin de
charger le carbone de trop donc
super
nous avons rendez-vous à Toulouse chez
aura Aero ici la transition écologique
est en marche on utilise aujourd'hui un
moteur thermique un moteur à combustion
qui est un moteur qu'on achète sur le
marché qui existe depuis de nombreuses
années demain c'est-à-dire avant la fin
de l'année 2023 on va remplacer tout ce
moteur thermique par un moteur
électrique qui est de plus faible
dimension et sur lequel on a un volume
très important pour accueillir des
batteries ça sera la première fois que
notamment un avion de formation capable
voltige
volera avec une solution 100% batterie
aura un héros ne compte pas s'arrêter à
l'avion électrique biplace il a pour
objectif la mise en service d'un avion
de transport inter régional hybride de
19 places d'ici 2027
[Musique]